Okay, let's get to audience questions first
one now.
Very timely.
Next week we have the second set of democratic
2020 primary debates a viewer wants to know.
Hey David, does Bernie debating with Warren
in the second debate help or hurt either or
both of them.
Yeah.
So last time Elizabeth Warren was on night
one and Bernie Sanders was on night two.
Um, there's sort of two answers to this question.
One is, let's deal with the specifics.
Is it better or worse for Bernie and Warren
to be on the same night, given that they are
appealing to a, a, a largely similar wing
of the Democratic Party before we even get
to that.
Remember, eventually it's gonna be just one
night.
This entire thing of having two nights is
only happening because there are way too many
candidates, including a ton of candidates
who have no chance whatsoever.
So understand that on the first night, along
with Elizabeth Warren and Bernie Sanders,
uh, Tim Ryan is going to be on the stage.
That guy has zero shot.
Marianne Williamson's going to be on the stage.
Amy Klobuchar, Delaney Hickenlooper Bullock.
They have no, and the only reason why we're
even talking about the possibility of them
being split up on separate nights is because
there are so many candidates and it's pushing
the debate into two nights that ends after
this debate.
They're going to be on the same debate stage
eventually.
So the conversation applies only to one more
debate, but let's actually play it out.
Uh, if they're appealing to widely the same
a slice of the Democratic Party, are they
better off Warren and Bernie by debating on
separate nights and being on each of their
respective nights, the sort of prominent progressive
choice or are they better off on the same
night in order to create the perception which
is not an inaccurate perception that there
are multiple good choices if your priority
is a more progressive candidate, particularly
when it comes to the primary economic issues
of inequality and economic fairness and so
on and so forth.
I believe that they are better off on the
same night.
Uh, they are two of the most prominent candidates.
If you look at who is in the lead right now,
it's Biden, Bernie Warren Harris and then
is it's uh, Buddha, judge Biden and Harris
are on night to booted.
Judge Warren and Bernie are on night one.
And by being there together, my hope is, and
we'll see if it actually is born out by their
performance, that they are going to eclipse
everybody else who is on that stage as clearly
being the folks who are the furthest to the
left.
And have the specific ideas and understanding
of the issues.
Bullock's going to be a non-factor.
Pete booted.
Judge is climbing.
He's, he's just desperate to climb.
His polling has gone nowhere.
If he wants to be in this thing, he has to
make a move to get closer to the top four
candidates.
He is going to be trying really hard but he
has a lot of trouble talking about substance.
I think Bernie and Warren are going to do
really well in relation to two.
Pete, Buddha, judge Delaney and Hickenlooper,
they're not going to be factors.
Uh, Amy Klobuchar often embarrasses herself
and last debate she did terribly.
I can't imagine she's going to do much Beto
or Rourke imploded in the last debate and
he'll be lucky to avoid any possible gaffes.
Tim Ryan looked shellshocked during the entire
last debate.
Can't imagine he'll do much in Marianne Williamson
has this sort of funny cult following but
she doesn't really have a shot.
So Bernie and Sanders being together I think
is going to show how strong the serious detail
oriented policy oriented progressive wing
of this primary is.
And I think that that's going to be a really
good thing for them.
Assuming of course that the timing and the
spread of the questions is not unfair in some
way.
Assuming that the format, even though it's
designed to prevent actually by definition,
serious depth on issues allows Bernie and
Warren to really show how much more detail
oriented and how much, uh, how much more sophisticated
their understanding a lot of these political
political issues is compared to the other
candidates.
If the format allows that, if the moderators
allow that to some degree, I think it will
be a really good thing for Bernie and Warren
to be up there together.
My guesses, you will start to hear discussions
after the next week's debate, uh, of there
should be a Bernie Warren ticket warrantee,
Bernie, Bernie, Warren, Warren, Bernie, whatever
your sort of preferences.
My expectation is that assuming things go
as they often do with both of them, uh, in
their respective debates, that is a conversation
that's going to be happening.
I'm not worried about them being on the same
stage and more importantly, by the third debate,
they will be on the same stage because there
won't be enough candidates to justify to nights.